this Darwin that people associate him
with atheism Darwin believed inca but
you're talking about hundreds of factors
must exist for life to exist on earth
the earth believed in God
Kant believed in God you know think
about that flip a coin 10 to the power
18 if you're non-muslim
listen I'm not telling you to take my
word as a fact do your research if
you're truthful you're gonna see there
is no real ATS how would you feel if you
died and you find out there is no God
so here apply a said much better than
what you will feel when you die and find
there is God we want to help out
everybody we are obligated to do that
and the best thing you can help someone
with save them from the Hellfire what's
better than mine because as ridiculous
as it is to us you still there's a -
there's a viewer and there he likes we
were saying he's one of his friends is
like man what are you doing maybe he
just came in so you listen to them
terrorists people you know it sees you
so the man is God I'll call you ice is
what these guys talk about blowing
something up what do you say to that I
laugh I will laugh the fact we were
sitting and talking to instead of trying
to kill you yes is if it's a fact that
we're not like that
but there's something uncommon or it's
very commerce is what's on the minds and
many of the people hawkers have been
program and sadly many people believe
this kind of nonsense is manufactured
fear that's out there I call it I'm not
going to go and tell you this lamb means
peace and all that in Islam is a
religion that has a system to punish the
oppressor if you do wrong you have your
punishment
it depends what I'm to have three green
light free license to kill ill Islam is
the last thing the last religion gonna
support there right you will not find in
any religion that will tell you how to
deal with every group of people based on
your relationship with them based on
their faith accept al Islam Islam
differentiate between treating
non-muslims who live with you in the
same country compared to non-muslims who
live and in another country compared to
Muslims who are have treaty with you or
non-muslims who have trade with you
compared to Muslims too
Muslims who declare war on you Islam
details all that right Aslam details of
that our prophet's wasallam said i
renounce a muslim who gives a promise to
a disability to add to a non-muslim and
betrays him that's the Prophet D now
renouncing a Muslim for a non-muslim
that's our Deen and we don't shy away
from all you hear about that Isis and
their ish and all that this is this is
again it's if you're gonna take your
knowledge from the media or from
Facebook you the only one to be blamed
right if Muslims that's all they want
they want to kill everybody trust me
nobody will be alive except Muslims
today we are almost 2 billion people and
I believe we're above we're more than 2
billion I mean since the first day we we
were able to understand things they've
been telling us we're 1.5 right there
well we're not increasing you know so if
we if we want to kill people just talk
to non-muslims who live in Muslim
countries right non-muslims were who are
impartial who are objective and most of
them who come from here to go there
right tell them how they are treated you
know so all this we're terrorists and
we're trying to kill people and we're
trying to do that come why don't you
visit a message and see how they treat
they can come visit you here thank you
you're more than welcome just come here
and let's see if trust me I promise you
you're gonna live a life right you're
gonna live a life if it's not your time
to die by Allah they can they can come
here to Miami visit you ask any
questions they want anything they want
that's that's that's a fair and just the
invitation and requests to come and I
always say come visit the Muslims come
and make the connection and the last one
is you have this growing trend we're
just it seems like copycat by Nature and
you have have you dealt with this many
Muslims now who will listen to the
professor and he's an atheist and now
many Muslims starting to doubt their
Deen and going towards saying well you
know I don't I don't we got a good book
here dialogue with the atheist now you
had a dialogue with
a Muslim who says yeah most of it I'm an
atheist mmm opposites oxymoron oxymoron
yeah have you dealt with these cases and
what do you say what are some things
that you say to have them to help get
them back on the clearway I mean if you
if you talk about an atheist an atheist
as they say helped you halfway to take
the shed because he says no God yes
right I was shared as lela lela no god
but Allah right so he already helped you
with the first half yeah now you need to
convince them that there is little and
that truly I don't believe there's real
or there's a good book but it's not
translated but it talks about there is
no real ATS right they can talk as much
as they want but at the end of the day
they believe in something what are they
going to be call it nature what are they
gonna call it intellect what are they
gonna call it a Big Bang whatever they
believe in something there is no way a
human being can exist without believing
that he came from something right these
atheists right they tell you you don't
prove God to us they all act
intellectually and scientifically so
they tell you we only believe in and
what's being experimented right so we've
never seen God we've never experimented
him in the lab so we don't believe his
existing well you apply that to
everything apply that to what you claim
to be the truth right you believe in Big
Bang did you see it did you experiment
it in the lab you believe in evolution
did you experiment it in that you have
you witness something going from one
form to another in the lab it's actually
based on faith not blind faith that's it
so so what's the difference between you
and us the only difference is you don't
want to say what you believe in is God
and we say it's good so and again it's
it's the the problem with a lot of
especially youngsters right Muslim shy
away from his nap because of all this
attack of misinformation he's not well
equipped to defend his deal he doesn't
even know what his deal
so when he's being hammered every day
how was his reaction you know what again
I cannot disassociate myself from this
religion it's all a reaction it's all
the reaction but with the same you talk
to an atheist has no merit whatsoever
there's no conflict I mean go read read
it should at one point those
philosophers who want to deny this
someone like Hume
he came to say listen nothing we see
exists anything we perceive as existing
in front of us it's a it's just
interpretation of our minds everything
outside is actually inside of us that's
what we just perceive things different
but there's nothing really exists they
reach that point yeah it's not that or
the others the idealism or
existentialism or naturalism it's all
just they're looking for something
because they're arrogant to accept that
there is a creator right and then they
tell you okay there's a creator then who
created the creator right and this is
this chain that keeps going back it
actually doesn't exist because doesn't
have an in yeah so it's just
philosophical argument that has no basis
right and the more and the intellectuals
are codified logic I mean they the
Giants I was a Socrates and Plato they
actually they believed in a creator 100%
and then I the great thinker talked
about one was that a little bit of sight
because we claim it's like science has
become a religion basically that a
little bit of science makes you an
atheist but in depth understanding of
science it makes you a believer hey I
have a hope about this it was in The
Times Magazine an article where when
they talked about life I don't know in
the 70s or something life they talked
about for for for life to exist on earth
they were talking about two components
need to exist right whatever oxygen and
water what
so as the more the science advanced over
the years they reach crazy number of
components factors need to coexist in
certain relationship for life to exist
so the argument they want to make there
is no way all these factors could
coexist at the same time without without
and someone who each annealed yeah so
they're saying how how science disproved
or prove the existence of God over time
I mean two things existing together and
there's a chance but you're talking
about hundreds of factors must exist for
life to exist on earth it's not only
water and an oxidant there are a lot of
other things we need as human beings to
exist so the more science discover these
things and the relationship with between
them they realize yeah they're each I
remember the chance the chance for life
with all these factors to exist if it's
by coincidence
is to flip a coin 10 to the power 18
times and all of the time it will be
face or head or tail that's the chance
for life to exist by itself on earth
flip a coin 10 to the power 18 right one
with 18 zeros flip it that many times
and every time it's gonna come head fall
which is yeah wow this is just a taste
for you guys to get to stimulate you to
really take the matter serious purpose
of life why am I here where am I going
when I die you know and just you know it
just you have more of a chance of
winning they say the lotto every day for
a month then this whole creation
everything to had created itself it just
doesn't make sense so look into you know
I often leave people with the homework
for people who are confused to ask the
Creator who created you for guidance you
know that's just place to start be
genuine and sincere and your order to do
your homework
and you know if I can say all these
people you you you brag about a lot of
them but as you said believe in God this
Darwin that people claim or associated
with it
Darwin believed Inca that's ironic these
are art believed in God Kant believed in
God you know think about that yes it's
just you have to read for yourself and
stop just being a sponge that is willing
to absorb people out their own people
want to harm you and at the end of the
day you believe in there's a story where
someone asking someone someone atheist
asking someone who believes him he said
how would you feel if you died it was
the the one who believes in God how
would you feel if you died and you'll
find out there is no God so he replies I
said much better than what you will feel
when you die and find there is God the
last thing and this is a treat I have to
mention it because this is something
that I was really fascinated with when I
started to see I always say not yet
Muslim Sheikh because I say everyone has
the potential to give birth to what's
already inside of them the natural way
of submitting to the crater not the
creation that's what a Muslim one who
has chosen freely to submit to the one
guy so that when I when I saw not yet
Muslims talking about we're out of time
I just gotta throw this in there because
you mentioned it so I could get this out
of you talking about the miswak mm-hmm
and now you're a dentist also and I saw
all that the tremendous benefits wrapped
up in this miss walk and use quoted a
study about this one mm-hmm
share that with us before we compare
that study was done by by Swedish
Swedish team and it was published in the
Swedish Dental Society this is this was
about thirteen years ago when I read it
you know and the whole study the whole
actually publication that that month or
year was about the miswak right it's a
study for about I remember forty pages
and it talked about the tremendous
benefits of the miswak and to the oral
care array or carry that's what we call
to the teeth in the way that keeps the
teeth healthy that calcium in the teeth
the the saliva a lot of natural things
in in the miswak where comes from
specific tree no that's another thing a
lot of people who go to hedge or they
just pick anything and that's selling on
the street as miss white yeah that's
something for you to pay attention not
every every branch
it's called miswak yeah this work really
comes from a specific tree and so you
want when you wanna buy it you want to
buy it you want it natural you want it
fresh and you want it from the real tree
yeah so there are specific places you
can ask and they will tell you but 100%
it has it has some chemicals very
beneficial to the gum the health of the
gum a lot of people always worried about
the teeth it's the gum is the house of
the teeth yeah if the gum is not good
you can have the perfect teeth and
eventually you will lose them so miswak
has a lot of benefit and even the way
the profits are seldom used to use the
miswak it was more on the gum rather
than the teeth right yeah because if the
gum is healthy
hopefully the teeth will be healthy yeah
we don't need to brush you still need to
brush any closing advice out there that
you want to give to the to the man yet
Muslims and also to the Muslims as we
wrap up all right very simple I you we
all looking for happiness there is no
human being out there if you ask them
what you're looking for that they will
disagree with you that they're looking
for happiness and comfort of mind if
your non-muslim listen I'm not telling
you to take my word as a fact do your
research if you're truthful you're gonna
see what makes sense to you and Allah
has ordained has control of your heart
just be sincere be do your homework and
trust me you will know where the truth
is if you're a Muslim you have a
treasure and Alonzo that will ask you
about the fact Allah chose you from all
these all these people to be Muslim do
not take it for granted there are a lot
of people out there
might need you to guide them to the path
by the permission of Allah if you're not
doing your work who gonna guide them
right so you might be instrumental in
the well-being of the zoom so don't
think always about yourself think about
the well-being of your own and of
mankind classdojo when he talks about
the homophily slap he said you're the
best OMA
brought forth to Tuhoe to mankind to
mankind he did not say you brought good
the best community brought forth to the
Muslims or to the believers or to
certain group of people he said to
mankind so we as Muslims have duly
taught mankind first we take care of
ourselves we educate ourselves we
connect with our lands the agenda where
he wants and then we will have so much
power to spread out there we want to
help out everybody we are obligated to
do that and the best thing you can help
someone with save them from the Hellfire
what's better than that is to save them
from the Hellfire so don't use the
excuse that oh I don't have money how I
can help you you don't need money for
that the Prophet SAW said most of the
messengers of Allah were poor right or
you need time you can make time right
you can make time you will have the
platform all you need is just teach
yourself educate yourself when you go to
speak speak out of knowledge as the
people as the people of knowledge if you
don't know and go spread the light and
the Prophet SAW Sunset Valley go
anywhere oh I couldn't be about me even
if it's one eye so you don't need to be
a scholar or have a degree in sharia for
for you to go and spread the word of
allah say what you know and what you're
sure and the world needs us too the
world is suffering is in dire need for
some guidance it's us that with what we
have and I promise you the next the next
era is for real Islam the next era is
for real Islam the next turn in the
history of the world is for real Islam
and mark my point and you will see so be
part of it right now install beautiful
the next era is that natural way of
submitting your will not to the creation
but to the Creator that's what Islam is
about worshipping the crater come out
the creation and it's there so many gems
of wisdom interact with us let us know
in the comments that things that you
picked up you've learned
contribute your part subscribe if you
haven't already and thank you for tuning
in here to the D show we'll see you next
time peace be with you
I said I'll lay COO